♪
(cheers and applause)
Ow! Ow! Spank me once,
shame at you.
Spank me twice,
now we're talking.
Clinton and Trump
are at it again.
The apple doesn't fall far
from the PC.
And damn it, Janet,
Animal Planet.
Holy moly, it's @midnight!
(applause and cheering)
I'm struggling actor
Kato Kaelin.
And now, here's your host,
a man whose tips are so frosted,
you'd think they were flakes!
Chris Hardwick!
(applause and cheering)
What's happening?
What's up? Yeah.
(applause and cheering)
-All right!
-(Kaelin whoops)
HARDWICK:
Welcome.
(cheers and applause)
All right.
Thank you, Kato Kaelin.
Welcome to @midnight, the show
(dramatically): that will
go down on you in a theater.
-(applause and cheering)
-Now,
let's see what's going on
in the chat room.
-Chat room.
-(high-pitched modem beeps)
-(laughter)
-(static)
(beep, static)
(laughter)
-All right.
-(cheers and applause)
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Now you get all of that.
Well, Clinton and Trump
are at it again. Yeah.
Donald "Second Marriage" Trump
is saying
the affair that President Bill
"Ruin Marriage" Clinton had
with Monica Lewinsky would pale
in comparison
to the multiple affairs he would
have if he were president.
There he is.
The tangerine dreamboat
told CNBC
that he'd be even sleazier.
Take a look!
-(laughter) -Yes!
-Did he just...?
-Yeah.
-(applause and cheering)
(Kaelin whoops)
Hillary Clinton herself,
a woman, had this response.
My mama always told me
the White House is like a box
of chocolates.
It's pretty on the outside,
but inside,
there's lots of nuts.
(laughter)
-Hee Haw. -Yeah.
-(applause and cheering)
It's Hee Haw.
They got very excited
about that.
KAELIN:
I... I...
She could be president some day,
maybe after,
like, a black guy. Uh...
-(laughter and groaning)
-KAELIN: No way. No way.
Personal animus aside,
politicians and corporate
billionaires go together
like cigars and Oval Offices.
I'm sure the Trumps and Clintons
run into each other
socially all the time.
So, comedians, what's a toast
Hillary Clinton might make
to Donald Trump?
Emo Philips.
Roses are red.
Violets are blue.
You are so, so, so lucky
nothing rhymes with orange.
-(laughter)
-HARDWICK: Yes.
Very good.
Points to Emo Philips.
(applause and cheering)
Wish we had a system to keep
track of that, but we don't.
Uh, Margaret Cho.
To Donald Trump,
the nicest, least racist man
I've ever met.
HARDWICK:
Yes. Excellent. Points.
(applause and cheering)
Jaleel White.
Donald Trump,
here is to your daughter.
Now she's pretty hot,
but just a reminder,
just because she's 18,
it's still illegal
to (bleep) your daughter.
HARDWICK:
All right.
-Oh.
-(cheers and applause)
-You get points for that.
-Salud!
Points for that.